all right welcome back everyone
hope you had a good weekend so this is
lecture 16 of cs229
and today we're going to start a new
chapter on unsupervised learning
right so so unsupervised learning will
be the broad
topic for the rest of this week and
parts of next week
and the specific topics for today are
the k-means algorithm
mixture of gaussians which is also
called the gmm or
gaussian mixture models and the
expectation maximization
algorithm and
ah to jumping into today's topics uh
so what we've seen so far is uh the
first few weeks first
three four weeks or so we covered
supervised learning
where we were trying to learn a function
that maps x to y
and we are given pairs of x y as our
training set or examples
and then after supervised learning we
went into
some learning theory we studied bias
variance uh trade-off in the bias
variance analysis
and saw a little bit into generalization
and then we um last week we saw
reinforcement learning
where the goal in reinforcement learning
is rather than minimizing some kind of a
loss function we want to maximize the
value by choosing
a suitable policy right and here value
is the long term
cumulative sum of discounted rewards and
we want to maximize the long term reward
by
choosing a policy now the new chapter we
are going to start today
starting today is unsupervised learning
and in the unsupervised learning case um
we are given a data set generally um
a collection of x 1
x 2 etc x
n right and
we do not have a corresponding y
variable
associated with each x variable we are
just given a set of collec
examples um x a set of x's where each
x i is in
r d in a d dimensional dual space for
example
and our goal is to learn some kind of a
structure in these axis
right we do not have a corresponding
correct answer
we do not have what's otherwise called
supervision of what the correct answer
is for each x
but in general we are just given some
some a collection of x's
and our and we the goal is to find some
kind of an interesting structure in
these xs
that hopefully gives us some new insight
right
so um we have seen logistic regression
before
and in the case of logics logistic
regression you know ah
x one x d
let me use a few colors here
we had some
we are given a data set like this and
our goal was to find
a separating hyperplane right that was
this is supervised learning because we
are given the correct answer that is the
color of each point along with the point
itself
right whereas in the unsupervised
learning a sim the the problem would
translate to something like this
right we are given some points
just the x's
and our goal now is to learn some kind
of an interesting structure here
right previously we had we had the
correct answer for each ah
for each input now we are just given a
collection of xs
and a reasonable structure to find in
this
are these two clusters
so loosely speaking we want to look for
for such structures with when we are
given just access
however this problem is generally not
very well defined
right in the first case for each point
we were told what the correct answer is
but consider a problem like this
right and if if you are asked to find an
interesting struct sub
structure in this kind of a data it
would be totally reasonable to say this
is one cluster this is one cluster and
this is another cluster
right and another totally reasonable
thing would be to say
this is one cluster and this is one
cluster right so in a way there is no
correct answer so to speak and our goal
is to learn some kind of an interesting
structure in the presence of such kind
of ambiguities
right the um
the way to you you want to think of this
is classification problems in the
supervised setting
are somewhat related to clustering
problems in the unsupervised setting
right where the cluster identity is like
the class label
and we want to looking at just the x's
find out
both how many number of classes there
are and also to which class each
example belongs to right and um
why would this be interesting so for
example
this would be interesting for example
for uh in examples where
supposing you have um you're working at
a marketing department and you have
information about your customers right
and the information about your customers
can be represented in in you know in in
some kind of a vector space
where you know you have the age of the
customer here
you have you know their um
annual income
and on another access you might have
their you know
geographical location
and each customer would be a point in
the space
right and now as a as a person who is
working in
in marketing you might be interested to
perform some kind of a market
segmentation
to identify you know groups of customers
so that you can do some kind of a
targeted
you know advertising or marketing
campaign or some such thing right so
that's just one example of how why
unsupervised learning might be you know
interesting so the first unsupervised
learning algorithm that will be seeing
is something called as the the k-means
clustering algorithm
the k-means clustering algorithm is
is uh pretty straightforward
this is probably one of the simplest
algorithms for unsupervised learning
k means alcohol
so we are given a data set of n
examples x
1 through x
n where each x i is in
rd right and our goal
is to group them into k clusters
right and for the purpose of the
algorithm we are we will assume that k n
is given to us
and the algorithm goes like this
initialize
cluster centroids
mu 1 mu 2
mu k so you have one
centroid per cluster where each of them
are in r d
randomly
right so each of these mu 1 mu 2 mu k
is a vector previously in in our
notations generally
having a suffix to a variable generally
meant it was a scalar
right but in in this case mu one
is a full vector right and there are k
such full vectors mu 1 through mu k
and we initialize them randomly and then
we repeat this until convergence
repeat until
convergence
for every i
where i denotes the example number
set ci
equal to
arg min
j
x i minus mu j
square and then that step one
and step two for
every j where j is now
where j indicates the cluster identity
set
mu j is equal to
sum over i equals 1 to n
indicator of
c i equals j
of x i
and sum over i equals 1
to n indicator
c i equals j
so what are we doing here k means is an
iterative algorithm
where we are given a set of n examples
which we index by i and we want to
identify k clusters where the k clusters
are
indexed by j we initialize the cluster
centroids randomly
where mu 1 through mu k are are each
a vector in r d and we repeat until
convergence where
for every for every i
we set ci here c
c you can think of c as an array of
length n where for each example there is
a corresponding c
i for every x i there is a corresponding
c i and we set c
i to be the identity that's the argument
of j
identity of the nearest mean right
and based on the set c i
vector or c i array we then recalculate
mu j
where mu j is calculated as the mean of
all
x i's for which c i equals j
this question
so as i said already for now let's
assume k is told to us
you know we are given what k is and this
is the algorithm
right and the way um it's it it's a
pretty straightforward algorithm where
we
ah where we alternate between
one step where we are either where we
are calculating the
cluster identities for each example and
in the other step
where we are recalculating the cluster
centroids
and this is probably seen through a
simple visualization
which we'll have a quick look at
any questions on this so far yes
[Music]
questions
so so the question is what happens uh
can we use an unsupervised learning
setting
to learn the different cluster centers
and use that as a classification
algorithm
yeah it might or it might not behave the
same way as a supervised learning
algorithm
yeah so supposing this is you know ah
think of this as a collection of points
that are given to us
where each green point is ah you know is
is is
a data point in uh x i in rd
and the way uh the algorithm works like
this
we here we assume k equals 2 and the red
x and the blue x you can think of them
as
mu 1 and mu 2 which are randomly
initialized
and in the first step what we do is for
each point for each point x
we identify the nearest cluster
right we we we set c
i to be the identity of that
cluster which has the smallest l2
distance between that point and the
cluster centroid so over here the red
dots
are those for which the red x is closer
and the blue dots
are those uh x's for which the blue x is
closer
right so this is like setting the the c
i's
in the first iteration and once we set
the ci's in the next step what we do
is recalculate the mu the mu j's
so what happened here i am going to go
back one slide so
at this stage we set all the cluster
identities
and in the next stage what we want to do
is recalculate
the red x that is the mu to be
at the middle of the red points
at the red circles and similarly
recalculate the
the blue mu to be the center of all the
blue circles
and that's what happens in the next
slide over here
right so this is this is just taking the
mean of all the points
of the corresponding color and then what
we do
we repeat and assign new cluster
identities
re-evaluate all the points to see which
new cluster centroid they are closer to
so what happened ah let me go back one
slide just to see the difference
so these two points which previously
belong to the
the old blue centroid
now got mapped to the new ah to the red
one
and then we re-evaluate the centroids
again and the centroids will now
move to the center and once we reach
here
in the next iteration i actually moved a
slide you know nothing changes
and we declare that the algorithm has
converged
right it's it's a pretty pretty simple
and straightforward algorithm
and now the the a few natural questions
to ask is
you know will this algorithm always
converge and will it always
give us the same same answers all the
time
so it can be shown
that the algorithm does always converge
and what we mean by convergence in this
algorithm has a special meaning
so if we consider this
loss function called j of
c comma mu to be equal to
i equals one through n
x i minus mu
c i square
and this is also called the distortion
function
and the k-means algorithm is basically
an algorithm
to minimizing this particular loss or
the distortion function
in the form of coordinate descent so
what is coordinate descent
coordinate design you can think of
coordinate descent as a variant of
gradient descent
where what we are doing is at each step
instead of minimizing the loss with
respect to
all the input variables we only minimize
the loss with respect to a few variables
by holding the others fixed right so
the the step number one
corresponds to minimizing the distortion
function by holding
mu fixed and optimizing c where
where we calculate new c's and
step number two corresponds to then
minimizing j again
by holding the c is fixed and optimizing
it with respect to mu
right so k means
is coordinate
descent
of the distortion function
j where in in one step we optimize it
with respect to c and the other step
with
we optimize it with respect to mu and
the result of the optimization
results in these in these closed form
rules
for recalculating the c's and muse
and we say that k means algorithm
converges
in the sense that eventually we are
going to reach some kind of a local
minima
of this j function right
it may so happen that
we may have minimized j but we may end
up toggling between
two sets of me or two sets of mus and
c's
alternating once we reach a local minima
though that happens extremely rarely
in practice but we will eventually reach
a state where j is no longer
minimized further we're going to flatten
out in j and most of the times
pretty much all the time in practice
that's going to result in some kind of
mu and c that does not change anymore
this j is non-convex which means
the the mus and the c's that we end up
in can change from run to run
if you start with a different
initialization you may end up with a
different set of mus and c's
right which which kind of ties back to a
question that was asked before
you know uh why do we you know ever need
to use the
label identities um and and not just
perform uh perform clustering and the
answer is
is that this is basically a non-convex
problem
and we can end up with different
different cluster identities depending
on the initialization
any questions on this yes question
so the question is by looking at a
function how do we determine whether it
is
convex or not in general it is
the answer is not always straight
forward so it is easy to show that
something is convex
by showing it as you know a composition
of
convex sub functions right
however showing something is not convex
is not always that straightforward
something could which may not appear to
be convex at first can sometimes with
some kind of reparameterization may end
up being convex etcetera
in this case it happens to be non-convex
any questions on this
cool
so given this clustering pro clustering
approach that we have seen
let us move on to something that is
slightly different
and also somewhat related which is the
problem of density estimation
so density estimation generally refers
to the problem
where we are given some number of data
points
given some number of data points
and this is in r you know think of it as
the x
axis and these points are residing in a
continuous space
right ah and the goal is
to now uh we assume that these points
are sampled from some kind of a
probability distribution
and because this this um
these points are are are coming on a on
a continuous distribution
the corresponding probability
distribution has some kind of a density
right it is not a probability mass
function but it is a probability density
function
right and given these points
points that look like this the question
is you know what is the
density function from which these points
were sampled and in general it's a very
hard problem
because if you want to fit this data
really really well
then the best possible fit would be a
density that looks like this
where it has you know like a direct
delta function over
every data point
you know
you know a peak that you know that
that's really really peaked over each
data point
and you can you know this this this ah
this is a valid valid density
but at the same time it does not feel
natural right
another another equally valid density
would be
something that looks like this
and
now this is also a valid density right
from which it could have been sampled
because there is nothing to the left
nothing to the right and there are some
values over here
you know that there are something where
there's some data so you might you might
have some kind of a density
and also this is also valid
right so all these are different
possible answers for what the underlying
density
is from which these points are are
calculated and kind of the the
fundamental problem of density
estimation is that
the density function has to be a
continuous
function in the case if if these were
you know um the outcomes of coin tosses
where
the the support was discrete then
maximum likelihood was
was pretty straight forward you could
you know treat them as a multinomial and
just count them
but whereas in density estimation we
need to come up with the smooth function
over discrete observations
right i say discrete observation because
we have a fixed number of observations
and we want to come up with with a
smooth estimate
so a common approach in density
estimation
is to use this model called the gaussian
mixture model
or it is also called the mixture of
gaussians
right the gaussian mixture model where
given some
given some data points that look like
this
right we want to we make this hypothesis
that there are these two
underlying different two different
distinct gaussian distributions
and there is one gaussian distribution
from which these were sampled
another gaussian distribution from which
these were sampled
and together you can take the sum of
these two gaussians
uh gaussian probability distributions
and say
this entire data set is sampled from
these two different gaussian
these two mixture of these two gaussians
and
the choice of k is something again uh is
is uh
similar to you know in k means it it is
something that we choose by
by uh you know visual inspection or
or uh or in general
seeing how well the data fit the
fit the number of k and the
the problem we have now is to
is to given this data set estimate the
two
gaussians from which the data set might
have come
right we are not told what the identity
of the two gaussians are if this were to
be
a supervised setting
then we would have you know
right they would come with some kind of
an identity
and we could have fit one gaussian here
and the other here
and this is exactly what we did in do
any of you remember
where we did something like this gda
exactly so in gda
we were we were told that x's come from
ah
are are sampled from gaussians and there
are these two different classes
class one and class two right and our
goal was to
take these x's along with their cluster
identities the corresponding y's
and estimate the mus and sigmas for the
two classes
right now in gaussian mixture model we
are
essentially generalizing gda in a way
where we are not given what the y labels
are we are just given the x's
and we also relax the constraint which
we had in gda that the covariance had to
be the same
in this case the covariance can be
different
and our goal is to now come up with some
kind of a
density p of x
that allows us to ah assign probability
density to the observed values
right so that is the ah that is the
setting in which
the gaussian mixture model comes into
picture
and the reason why
why we are interested to even calculate
this p of x
there are many reasons why calculating p
of x could be interesting
so here's one example
so here's a completely made up example
supposing
uh supposing you are an aircraft
manufacturer
where let's assume
the the uh the parts that we manufacture
have two kind of attributes
um let's say you know um
heat tolerance
and if any of you are you know are in
aeronautics what what might be another
you know let's say let's let's call it
um um
you know heat tolerance and and
um whatever power output whatever that
means
so let's assume there are there are
there are these two kind of um
attributes that are that are therefore
some part that we manufacture and in
general what we observed that
if we were to plot the
the the every manufactured part as a
point here
we might observe that
most of the normal parts
fall along some kind of a distribution
like this
maybe there are you know two different
kinds of
uh sub types of parts may be based on
the material or something where
some of them uh fall in distribution
some of them fall in this kind of a
distribution you know
whatever be the reason but you know
generally let's assume that
you know normal looking parts fall in
this kind of
belong to this kind of a probability
distribution now suppose
we want to we want to uh have some kind
of an automated anomaly detection
where we want to detect that you know
some part is is faulty for some reason
right for example a part that may
that has this attribute right
we want to identify that this point over
here
is is uh is faulty and
at first it it might appear you know
even though this looks visually away
from
this kind of a heat map if you were to
look at any one of the axis alone
it looks pretty normal right just from
the heat tolerance point of view it's
kind of you know in the uh close to the
mean and if you just look at the power
output it is also kind of near the mean
but it is this combination that makes it
kind of you know an anomalous
example right and the the wave
ah this kind of an anomaly detection is
ah can be carried out in practice is to
construct
you know a density estimate p of x for
these points
where the where this p of x assigns high
probability for
anything that falls in this region
and p of x assigns low probability for
anything outside this region
right and a common approach to doing
this kind of a density estimation is to
use mixture of gaussians
and the way we go about
doing mixture of gaussians is
so first what we are going to do is to
provide you an algorithm to do mixture
of gaussians
and we are going to provide construct
this first algorithm
based purely on intuition
and then what we are going to do is
describe this general framework called
expectation maximization
and then re-derive gaussian mixture the
gaussian mixture model
using this framework and see that we end
up with the same algorithm that we got
using
intuition the
expectation uh maximization that we're
going to see next
is a more general framework that works
for a broad class of
um of of
generative models these are examples of
generative models
and the gaussian mixture model is just
one such
one such model which can be solved
through expectation maximization
this question
restrict like what is the upper bound
for the frequency that you will tolerate
on the pdf because
the k will fit best as the k sk
approaches the number of data points
right
so the the question is uh i guess
to to kind of summarize this how do we
find out k and
uh it is true that as we increase the
number k
we kind of fit the data better and
better
and in order to kind of think of what's
the best value of k
i will leave this as a thought exercise
for now and we'll come back to this
probably next week
try to see how you can apply you know
what we learned in um in learning theory
bias and variance
you know how how can you you know
give some thought on how you can apply
bias variance analysis
on this kind of a problem right we will
come back to this later for now we'll
you know for for for today and for uh
the rest of this week we're going to
just cover more algorithms and we'll you
know
come back to it later with you know and
see how we can
kind of approach it in a more principal
way you know for now you know
as a mental exercise see how you can
apply bias variance
analysis in this kind of a setting
right so in the mixture of gaussians
or gaussian mixture model
so we are ah we are given a training
set of just x's
right and then we are going to assume
there is
this
z i which belongs to
a multinomial distribution
parameter with parameter phi where
v j is greater than equal to zero and
the sum over all
j equals one through k v j
equals one
right and phi j
is basically
v j is the probability that
z i equals j
right and then we have x i
given z i
equals j to be
distributed from a normal distribution
of mean
mu j and covariance sigma j
right so this is describing the model
so the the way we assume the model works
is that first
we sample the class identity
z from some kind of a multinomial
distribution
right and then one you know once we once
we have a sample the identity
we generate you know an observation x
condition on the z value that we sampled
from what some particular
gaussian distribution with mean mu j and
and covariance ah sigma j
this is very similar to gda right in gda
the the the differences between this and
gda is that in gda
we called z as y here we just calling it
z
and that is a common pattern that you
will see when you know in
in the algorithms where we are doing
full observation which becomes a
supervised setting
the variables that we call y we end up
calling them as z
in unsupervised setting because they are
not observed
right in this case there is this
underlying z
that we do not observe that is sampled
from some multinomial distribution
and depending on the identity of the
cluster
that we that we sample the observation
is then sampled from a corresponding
gaussian distribution
that has a mean and covariance specific
to that cluster right
in these cases z i's because they are
not observed
are called latent variables
so latent variable is a fancy name for a
random variable that we have not
observed
we've just not seen what what what its
value is
and that's why we call it latent yes
question
so fee over here is the you you can
think of it as the class prior
you know the the class prior that we had
in gda
uh this just tells us of all the
examples x's that we have
what fraction of them belong to cluster
j
good question
and now in
gda
we performed maximum likelihood
estimation in gda
and our maximum likelihood objective
was
in gda it was log p of
x comma y where
mu sigma and p were the parameters
right so this was
the log likelihood objective in gdl
right whereas in gaussian mixture model
we do not observe y
right and so in the in the gaussian
mixture model
our objective will be to maximize log
p of x given for for
phi mu sigma and this will be our
likelihood function
that's the only difference over here the
objective was the full joint
distribution
over here we would have liked to do the
same
but we haven't observed the work the
corresponding wise we should call as
these here right there
they're not observed so we cannot
construct a likelihood function because
we won't know what value of z to plug in
in this expression
right if you had observed them it was
pretty straight forward we would have
been just doing gda
and so instead what we do is maximize
log p
of x right and log p of x can that
can also be written as
log sum over z
p of x comma z
phi mu
right so we write out the full joint
distribution
and marginalize out the latent variable
any questions how we went from this to
this this question
so the question is ah shouldn't z also
contribute to
our likelihood objective and the answer
is
if we had observed z then yes it should
have
but we don't know what z is so it you
know it cannot
so so the question is we are assuming
there are k clusters
and given a setting uh you know some
value for k
shouldn't we therefore uh account for
for the cluster identity
are making an assumption about k but we
do not
know which of those k clusters each
point belongs to
right so our objective is to now
maximize
this expression which is the same as
this expression
right and for the rest of of uh you know
today's lecture and and throughout
it it can be useful to set up you know
some kind of ah
terminology so for example p of z
we will call it class prior
or in cases where z is not
discrete but it is continuous we'll just
call it prior
right p of x comma z
we will call it the model
because it describes the full data
generating process the joint
distribution
always describes the full data
generating process and that's always
called the model
right and z in unsupervised settings
is called latent
because we do not observe it latent is
just a fancy word for unobserved
and p of z given x we will call it the
posterior
right and finally p of x
so p of z is called the prior and p of x
will be called the evidence
evidence because x is what we observe
that is the evidence based on which we
are performing
inference right this is just terminology
and this terminology is is
pretty standard and you know used in
many papers many many books
so our goal is to maximize
the likelihood using the evidence
[Applause]
right and this
the way we go about doing that is
right so to directly maximize
this evidence ah directly maximizing
this
likelihood if we were to attempt it
the way we did it with gda of taking
derivatives setting it equal to zero and
solving for the parameters
you will observe that you you won't get
a close form expression for this
you can try it out you know you won't
get a close form expression for
the way we got it with gda in gda we got
a closed form expression because we had
observed both
x's and z's we called it y's and if we
had observed both x's and y's here
we would have gotten a closed form
expression but because
the z's are not observed and we are
taking this
marginalizing them if you work it out we
will not get close form expressions
so instead what we will do is
just like you know taking inspiration
from k means
we are going to first ah imagine
or are come up with some kind of
an estimate for z i's first so
the algorithm that we are going to do is
repeat until
convergence where this is you know just
taken
inspired by k means
we'll call it the e step
for each i comma j
set w
i j to be equal to
p of z i
equals j given
x i parameters phi
mu sigma
and the l step
update the parameters
v j equals 1 over n
equals 1 to n w
by j
mu j is some over
i equals 1 to n w
i j x i
over i equals 1 to n
w i j
and sigma j
is equal to
somewhere i equals 1 to n
w i j
x i minus mu j
transpose divided by
i equals 1 to n w
i j
so what we did is
we start with some random initialization
so ah randomly initialize parameters
and so the repeat will start after we
randomly initialize it randomly
initialize mu
phi and sigma
right start with some random
initialization and think of this as the
way we randomly initialize the cluster
centroids and k
means right and based on the random
initialization
in k means for each point
we associated it to the nearest cluster
centroid
right and the the the kind of similar
operation that we are going to do here
is for each point we are going to assign
a weight to each cluster centroid
specific to that point
where the weight is the posterior
distribution of p of z given x
right so given a point we calculate a
posterior distribution of the
probability that this point belongs to
a particular centroid
and this is just the posterior the
posterior distribution
we are going to call it a weight
and once we calculate this weight we are
going to reweight all our
data points to calculate the
corresponding mus and sigmas
right so for example x i will
ah may belong to will have a weight of
let us say if there are if there are say
centroids where k equals 3 then
p of z i
equals j
given x i right this could be some kind
of
multinomial distribution like 0.1
0.7 0.2
right where this belongs to k equals 1 k
equals
r 2 k equals 3 where if the centroid mu
was
was close to mu 2 was close to
x i then it would have a higher weight
and you know
these two are farther away so it has a
lower weight
in in case of k means
we would do a hard assignment of every
point
to one cluster only but over here we are
doing a soft assignment
where every point has
has a soft assignment in the form of
this probability distribution
for all the cluster centroids and the
the probability assigned
to the centroid that is closer to the
point
by closer here we mean in a
probabilistic sense where it is
it has a high likelihood in that in
in that clusters gaussian distribution
then it will have a high posterior
probability and we do this kind of a
soft assignment
of every point to to the set of all
clusters
and using the the calculated weights
we recalculate the muse and sigmas
using the weighted data set here
every every point i contributes to every
centroid j and the contribution is
weighted by the corresponding wij
questions
yeah so the question is will this have a
closed form expression um
yeah yeah so so the question is so for
this i would i would uh remind you
uh in in case of gda we had calculated a
posterior that was
very similar and if you remember the
posterior had a form of
yeah it had the form of a logistic
regression in that case however we
limited ourselves to two
two points to two classes and we also
had a constraint that
sigma was common to all of them but in
this case when we relax that
constraint what we will observe is that
the posterior takes the form of a soft
max
it takes a form of a soft max that uses
quadratic features
quadratic features of xs right but ah
for for a fixed value of you know for
small case you can you know come up with
with with an expression for this and in
fact you'll be doing this in your
homework so that will be clarified in
your homework as well
right so um so inspired by
k means here is a version of you can
think of
the gaussian mixture model as soft
k-means you know people call it
the soft k-means as well we call it soft
because
um in the assignment phase in k means
right in k means it was a hard
assignment
right this was this corresponds to the e
step
the uh in k means uh the cluster
identity was a hard assignment
you can think of k means as a way in
which we calculate a posterior
distribution
which is always one hot
right if if you if we calculate these
kind of posterior distributions then we
effectively
get k means out of uh gmms right
and in the equivalent of the m step
was the way in which we were
recalculating muse ah
the mu js we use only those
those x's for which the cluster identity
matched the
uh the corresponding cluster
and over here instead of instead of
having ah
an indicator function we are going to
use this
soft assignment weight
any questions
yeah so if w's are one hot
uh then this this will essentially be
you know uh k means yes question
so the question is how do we calculate w
i j if we have not observed the i's this
disease is that a question
yeah so here uh in order to calculate
this
we don't need to know z i's
right so we don't need to so we are just
cons
we are just constructing the probability
that z i could be equal to j
right and the way we go about doing this
is to use the bayes rule
right and the way you use the bayes rule
um
[Applause]
right so and and this can be calculated
as
p of you know so p of z
given x is equal to p of
x given z times p of z
over sum overall of
z p of x given z
times p of c right
over here p of x given z is
normal distribution so this is gaussian
right and p of z is just multinomial
right and in the denominator uh you know
it is same
the the same terms gaussian and the
multinomial but you sum it over all the
classes
and you will see that you know just the
way you showed it in homework one for
gda
where in gda this took the form of a
logistic regression
uh here you can actually show that it
takes the form of a soft max
it's very similar calculation
any questions
right yeah so this is basically the
gaussian mixture model
where we derive the steps to be by
taking inspiration from k-means
right and we are intentionally giving it
the names the e-step and the n-step
because next we're going to talk about
the e-m algorithm and
we're going to derive it in a more
principled way and we're going to end up
with the same update rules
right and this is you know think of this
as
soft k means
right
now we are going to switch gears and
talk about
the e m algorithm
so the e m algorithm is also called the
expectation maximization algorithm
that is an algorithm where it gives us a
framework
of maxima of performing maximum
likelihood estimation
when some variables are unobserved right
it is it it is used in cases where
we have a functional form for the joint
p of
x comma z and x and z could be anything
but z's are not observed so expectation
maximization
right expectation maximization is an
algorithm
where we perform mle
in the presence of latent variables
right so where the true model
is p of x comma z
with some parameters um theta
and if we observe x and z
jointly if everything is observed then
the problem is very simple
we perform simple maximum likelihood
estimation
but when z
is unobserved
we want to instead perform
maximization
of the objective l theta equals
log p of x
where z is marginalized and the em
algorithm
or the em framework gives us a framework
for achieving this
where we maximize log p of x in an
indirect way rather than directly taking
the derivatives and setting them to 0
and so on
now before we go into the em algorithm
some kind of
it can be useful to have some kind of a
context here so the em algorithm was
was uh uh discovered some sometime in
the
i think early 1970s where uh you know
where people were trying to
perform mle in the presence of
unobserved
unobserved data and it so happens that
this
this framework is so general and so
powerful
that there are it has been adapted in so
many different ways
and it has been you know minor
extensions to the em algorithms
uh are there in so many different forms
but this framework
is is somewhat central and
understanding em in a deep way will be
extremely useful
if you are interested in things like
deep generative models
right so in um over the last few years
there has been
uh you know tremendous growth in deep
generative models
where you might have heard of you know
variational auto encoders
generative adversarial networks or gans
or flow based models
glow based models and all of them
understanding all of them
would be a lot much easier if you really
understand the em algorithm well
because the em framework gives you a
kind of a mind map where you can place
all these different algorithms
and kind of understand the strengths and
weaknesses and and you know what's
common between them what's different
between them
and so on so em algorithm is is uh
one of the key algorithms to um
for for even modern deep learning or
deep generative
deep generative models right so
before we jump into e m algorithm we are
going to first
look at
something called as jensen's inequality
so jensen's inequality
is a is a very general ah
probabilistic inequality that's used you
know in
in very many places ah in probability
theory and applied probability theory
and it will show up in in our derivation
of em algorithm as well so
you can think of jensen's inequality as
a probabilistic tool that we will use in
deriving uh em
but jensen's inequality by itself is is
is a very generic and you know commonly
used inequality in in
probability theory so lets
lets assume a function f to be convex
right assume f to be a convex function
which means
um f double prime of x
is greater than equal to zero for all x
right and we say that f
is strictly convex
if f double prime of x is
greater than zero for all x
right so the ah the mental picture to
have is
f of x and this is x
f of x and x so this
is an example of a convex function
convex functions are bowl shaped
functions right and they can have
a 0 second derivative in a few places
where f prime of x is greater than or
equal to 0
but in a strictly convex function the
second derivative is never exactly equal
to zero it is always
greater than zero so if there are
straight lines
for for certain input ranges in your
functions then it can still be convex
but for a strictly convex function there
cannot be straight lines
right it should always be curving
upwards
now the jensen's inequality tells us
that
expectation of
f of x where x is some random variable
is always greater than or equal to
f of expectation of x
where
f is convex
so this is jensen
so the jensen's inequality tells that
the expectation
of f of x where f is a convex function
x is a random variable and the
expectation is taken with respect to the
randomness in x
will always be greater than equal to f
of the expectation of x
right and moreover if f
is strictly convex
strictly convex
then
expectation of
f of x
equals f if then
then if
expectation f of x equals f of
e of x
then x equals
expectation of x with
probability 1.
there's a lot of jargon here we will uh
dissect it in a moment
so to ah just to restate it again
jensen's inequality says
if f is a convex function and x is any
random variable
then expectation of f of x is greater
than equal to f of expectation of x
and moreover if f is strictly convex
then this statements hold true and this
held
statement holds true only if f is
strictly convex
now if expect the the statement is
if f of x equals ah expectation of f of
x equals f of expectation of x
then it must be the case that x equals
expectation of x with probability 1
which means essentially x is a constant
right now what is this mean
to to kind of understand this more
intuitively
now this this picture can help
right let this be some function ah
f of x
and this is basically
x right and use a different color here
let us also assume that x
is has a probability distribution
associated with it
right so the green dotted line
represents the
probability density of of the random
variable x
and f is some function of x
right now expectation of
x or e ah would be somewhere here
so let us call this
expectation of x right so expectation of
x is is um
so think of it as like the mu if this is
a gaussian right that's the expectation
of the random variable
right and now um
f of expectation of x so ah in in the
case where
x ah let us assume x takes only two
possible
values so let us assume um
let us draw another picture here so
this is x this is
f of x let's assume x takes only two
possible values
let's assume it's a discrete
distribution here we we
here x was continuous but to understand
jensen's inequality let's
assume a discrete setting where
x takes only two possible values
this value and this value may be they
are you know
0 1 2 3 4 1 and 10 let us assume
x takes any one of these values and the
mean
of x if it takes ah with probability
half the value one and its probability
have value ten
then expectation of x will be five
point five right so
expectation of x equals 5.5
is 5.5 yeah 5.5 and
this over here is
f of expectation of x
right does that make sense this is the
expectation of x you evaluate f
at expectation of x and you get f of
expectation of x that is the
right hand side right now similarly um
with probability half f of x can takes
this value and with probability half
another half f of x takes this value
right so this is let us call this
a and b so this is f of a
and this
is f of b
right and expectation of f of
n f of b is basically the midpoint
between
f of a and f of b right because with
probability half it takes this value
with probability half it
takes this value so the expectation ah
of f of x is
this one right and this
is
expectation of
f of x right and it it so happens that
this point
will always be the midpoint of
will always be the midpoint of the chord
connecting f of a and f of b
right and what jensen's inequality is
telling us is that
this point the point that that's the the
midpoint of the chord connecting two
points
on f will always be higher than
this point right so
f of expectation of x is always less
than
the expectation of f of x
right is this clear
can you raise your hand if you
understood this
some of you have not okay
can anybody tell me what what's what
what's what's still confusing here
i can just go over it again so f is a
convex function
which is kind of bending upwards right
and the x axis is is
denotes some random variable right and
in this case just for the purpose of
understanding
jensen's inequality let's assume x is
is is uh takes on two values one of two
values either one or ten
with equal probability so the
expectation of x is therefore five point
five
right that's that's over here now f
of 1 you know let's call it a you know f
of a
is is this point so this is f
of a so the height from the x axis to
this point this is f of a
and similarly if this is b this is f of
b
and the expectation of f of x is
therefore the midpoint
connecting these two points right and
that comes over here
and the x f of expectation of x
where expectation of x was was ah 5.5
is this point that comes over here
and jensen's inequality is is therefore
essentially saying
that the chord connecting any two points
of a convex function
always lies above the chord itself
right the expectation expectation of f
of x
is is higher than f of expectation of x
right kind of understood
all right okay let's let's ah move on
and it also tells us that
if f is strictly convex right f is
strictly convex
then f of x equals
if it is f is strictly convex and if
expectation of f of x equals
f of expectation of x then x equals the
expectation of x
itself which means x is essentially a
constant
what does that mean so here is an
example of
f of x that is strictly convex
right now um
if expectation of f of x
equals f of expectation of x when can
that be possible
right expectation of f of x equals
f of expectation of x when can
let's assume you know a and b are here
right
this is expectation of f of x and let us
say this
is f of expectation of x right
if f is strictly convex
and if the two are equal
f of x equals expectation of x then the
only way that is possible
that you know f of x equals expectation
of f f of x
is if x has a probability density
right now over here in this dotted line
essentially
i am drawing the probability density of
x which is like a dirac delta function
where it has
all its mass concentrated at just one
point
right and in this case this is
expectation of x
and f of expectation of x is here
and also because x always takes on this
value with probability 1
f of x also always takes on this prob
this
value with probability 1 and therefore
f of x equals f of expectation of x
equals
expectation of f of x because
essentially you know the equivalent of
the chord connecting two points
has length zero here right all the
values of f of x
are always here and x always evaluates
to the same value
next question
so what's the expectation of a
continuous random variable
if x is a continuous random variable
and it has a pdf let's call it um
small p of x right then expectation of
x is equal to the integral of x times
p of x d x
so p in this case is some probability so
the green line
the green dotted line is p of x here my
question is what is e
so oh what's e of f of x so e of f of x
uh so if
e of f of x
is equal to the integral of f
of x p of x d
x
good question
right so this is this is jensen's
inequality
and and the reason why we require f to
be strictly convex
is because if f were not strictly convex
then you could have a case where x
x is f of x is flat in some place
and
x has this ah density and
ah expectation of f of x would be here
and f of expectation would be here and
also
ah f expectation of f of x would also be
the average
f of x in this region which is also a
constant so expectation of f of x
would be equal to f of expectation of x
ah even though x is not constant because
f has a flat region somewhere
this question
so the question is uh uh in in
in the convex case can we assume that
so for for um i mean for this
for this case yeah so if if um
for this to hold without uh
x being a constant for x two
and f of x to be the same then all of x
should be distributed in a region where
f is flat
yeah that's right right
so what are some examples of convex
functions
anybody example for convex function
y equals x square
example for concave function
minus x square y equals minus x square
yeah yeah
that's good so um
examples of
convex
concave and
strict yes or no right so convex
function we saw
x square is convex
minus x square is therefore concave
right and is this strictly convex
and therefore also strictly concave
right now another function um
y equals or f of x equals
equals say mx plus c straight line
is convex by definition it is convex
a straight line is convex and it is also
concave
but is it strict no right it's fine
great now um what about
e to the x yes convex
minus e to the x is therefore concave is
it strict
what about log x
so log x is concave
and therefore minus log x is convex
right and it is strict
cool now how does this
how is this useful for expectation
maximization
yes question
yeah a straight line is always convex
and concave
because
is is is so f double prime is equal to
zero
and the definition of convex is that f
double prime should be greater than or
equal to zero
so and it is equal to zero so it
satisfies greater than or equal to zero
and similarly for concave it is less
than or equal to zero and its equal to
zero so it satisfies less than or equal
to zero so
now um so using jensen's inequality
and with these observations that
expectation of f of x is greater than
equal to f of expectation of x
and and so on
we can adapt jensen's inequality to the
concave case
where basically it says if
f is concave
right example
f of x equals log x
right then the inequality will switch so
the expectation
of log
x instead of greater than equal to will
be less than or equal to
log expectation of x
right this is also jensen's inequality
so now let us derive the e m algorithm
right so in the e m algorithm
our goal
is to maximize
log p of
x i comma ah
theta where by theta mean you know all
the
parameters i equals 1 to n right you
want to maximize this that is the goal
what what we are trying to achieve this
is our end goal we want to maximize
log p of x but however maximizing log p
of x
can be hard because the z's are
unobserved
if these were observed this was very
easy but z's are unobserved so it's hard
right that's the case where that's the
setting we are in
and now
for the derivation i'm going to
assume one example so i'm just going to
write it as
log p of x comma theta
and i'm going to leave the summation out
but basically the whole
the entire derivation that we are going
to do you can include the summation and
everything will hold
right this just to simplify notation
right
so log p of x we want to
maximize this that's our goal right so
the first thing we are going to do
is write
log p of x comma theta
is equal to log of
the sum over z
p of x z theta
right first we are going to marginalize
out z
and then once we do that
we will define an you know some
arbitrary probability distribution
called q over z and write this as
log sum over z
q of z
times p of x
comma z theta
divided by q of c
where q of z
is greater than 0 for
all c some arbitrary
probability distribution over z it could
be anything whatsoever any kind of
probability distribution over z
such that q of c is greater than zero
everywhere this question
so so the question is uh it's uh you
know why is this a hard problem
so it is hard because we are having a
summation over here
right and in general when in in the
cases where z
is continuous this will be an integral
right and that integral can be
you know arbitrarily complex
it can be computationally expensive it
can be analytically not possible
in cases when we want an analytical
solution
good question ah so
we come up you know q can be any
distribution whatsoever as long as q of
z is greater than zero for all z
and and now we can see that
this can be written as log
expect
right what did i do here
nothing basically so this is the
definition of expectation
right so this is a function of you know
z some function of z right and
ah think of this as the probability and
this is some function
and therefore this is just the
expectation
is this clear yeah okay so this is
this just you know the expectation
and now we make use of jensen's
inequality and note that
log of the expectation of something is
greater than the expectation of the log
of the same thing
right and so this is going to be greater
than or equal to
expectation of z q
log p of x comma z
theta over q of c
this question
f here is log and log is
concave log is concave
right and this is our random variable x
right any any any uh questions on how we
apply
how we went from here to here this is
probably the most crucial step
right all good ok
and this what we see here
we will call this you know give it a
name
we will call it elbow evidence lower
bound
right so it is the elbow of
q and
lb of x
q theta
right and jensen's inequality tells us
that
the elbow you know which is defined to
be this term
is always less than or equal to
our objective that we want to maximize
right which which means now if we find
thetas and q's such that we are
maximizing the elbow
then implicitly for the same values of
theta
log p of x is also going up
does it make sense elbow
is defined to be is by jensen's
inequality elbow is always a lower mound
for log p of x our likelihood
both of them have theta in them right
now if we find values of theta such that
we are maximizing the elbow
then it necessarily means that log p of
x at that value of theta is higher
and jensen's inequality gives us that
inequality
yes question
all right so this is the uh so this is
the elbow
and this term elbow is uh something you
will
very commonly encounter if you're
reading reading research papers about
you know generative models or deep
generative models um
you know this is this is a widely used
term
and elbow means you know the the
the lower the lesser side of the
jensen's inequality
of log log p of x
right and our goal is to now
well before we go into our goal let us
make a few more observations
now log p of x is greater than equal to
elbow at all times
that's what jensen's inequality says but
are there cases when
log p of x is exactly equal to the elbow
right are there cases
are there cases when
log p of x theta
is equal to
of x q and theta
and the answer is yes
it is yes because of the second part of
jensen's inequality that we saw
right so jensen's inequality
we also saw that if f is strictly convex
log x is strictly convex
right if f is strictly convex
then expectation of f of x
expectation of f of x equals
f of expectation of x if and only if
x is a constant right so
this is one side of jensen's inequality
this is the other side of jensen's
inequality
right and the 2 will be equal
if and only if the term inside
is a constant that's what
jensen's inequality told us because log
is strictly concave
this question
in this case we want we want this entire
term over here
to be a constant now are there cases so
the next
question is are there you know under
what circumstances is this entire term
over here
always a constant that's that's that's
what we're going to answer next
it has to be it has to be independent of
z so it is constant with respect to z
right so the question now is
in order to make this inequality an
equality
because because log is
because log is strictly concave the
inequality becomes an equality
if and only if p of x comma
z theta over
q of z equals some constant c
right and now this implies
that take q of z over there
q of z is equal to
1 over c times p of x comma z
right and we also know
that
because this is just a proportionality
constant
we can write this as q of z is
proportional to p of x comma z
so q of z is just
proportional to p of x comma z and in
order to make this
equal to
we just use the calculate the
proportional normalizing constant
that you are summing over z p of x comma
z theta
right and this is basically p of
x comma z theta divided by
when you marginalize out z you just get
p of x
theta and this is equal to p of z given
x
theta
so the question is why did we normalize
it with p of x so because q of z is
proportional to this
and in order to and we know that this is
a probability
uh distribution which means it has to
sum up to one
so this must the normalizing constant
necessary must necessarily be
the uh um some sum of this
so the denominator is this term that is
summed over all possible values of c
but if something if you're summing a
distribution to one
is it multivariate and it helps you to
sum over x and z
so this is a distribution over z p of x
z
could be anything x could be continuous
right q of z is a distribution over z
that must sum up to 1
right and that's proportional to p of x
x comma z and
the the it is proportional and the
corresponding normalizing constant
must necessarily be the um
the the sum over the numerators for all
possible values of z
because it must it must sum up to one
right so when q of z
equals p of z given x then
jensen's inequality will
change into an equality
right lots of moving parts yes so we
started with
we started with log p of x right and
wrote it out as as you know the sum over
z of the joint
you know there is nothing fancy going on
here right we are just marginalizing out
the
z and then we multiply and divide it by
some arbitrary distribution q and by
multiplying it and dividing it
this the numerator allowed us to write
it in the form of
an expectation right and the
ah and this stayed in the denominator
and once we wrote it as an expectation
we had log and the expectation
right so initially we started with the
log likelihood and therefore we use
the concave version of jensen's
inequality so this log
and this expectation are then swapped
right and we get a greater than equal to
expectation of log
right and once we get this you know this
is basically jensen's inequality
the one side and the other side of
jensen's inequality
we call the lower the lower end of the
jensen's inequality we just called it
elbow we just gave it a name
right and then we use the the uh
the corollary of jensen's inequality to
look for conditions when this inequality
will be exactly equal to
right and because log because log
is strictly convex the corollary of
jensen's inequality gives us a condition
when this inequality becomes an equality
and the condition
is that this term must be a constant and
then in order
for this to be a constant with respect
to z
it is necessarily the case that q of z
must be equal to
the posterior distribution of z given x
right whenever
q equals z given x at that value of
theta
then jensen's inequality becomes a
strict becomes an equality
right and now given these two
yes questions
so why is uh uh yeah this
all right so we want to
find the condition that p of x comma z
divided by q
this is equal to some constant right so
now
let it be equal to some unknown constant
c right so you can take
q of z over here right and once you take
it over here this becomes proportional
because of some constant times
right so now what we we also know that
sum over q
of z equals 1 right which means
the sum over all of all of the right
hand
uh terms must be equal to
c itself right and
we divide it by c and we get exactly
ok so q of z is equal to the posterior
of z given x at that value of theta
thank you thanks for asking um
so based on this we we come
we write the ah
the e m algorithm or the more general
form of the e m algorithm
we call it the more general form because
throughout this throughout this uh
setting
we have not assumed any specific form
for p of x and z
right it could be the mixture of
gaussians it could be any algorithm
this derivation holds for any such
latent variable model
all right so that gives us the
algorithm so the e m algorithm
the e m algorithm basically tells for
so we have the e step
for each i
set q i
of z i is
equal to p of z
i given x i comma theta
and the m step
set theta
equal to
r max theta of
i equal to 1 to n
alpha of
x i q i
comma theta
right so what did we do
we basically ah
you basically get this e m algorithm
where
the corresponding e step is to set q
to be the posterior distribution of
p of z given x and in the m step
we set theta to be equal to the arg max
of the elbow
now why will this why will this work to
see why this works
let's see this diagram
now lets suppose this is theta its not x
this is theta
right and this
is is arm so let us assume this is our
so this is log
p of x theta right as we vary theta
log p of x gives us different values
this is not the density this is the
likelihood because the x axis is theta
and not x
right and it's a dotted line because we
don't know it right
it is hard to calculate we have to
marginalize out x which may be in
an integral and what we got from
this elbow is that for any given value
of q
the elbow of uh elbow of
of x for q and theta will always be less
than or equal to
log p of x that's what jensen's
inequality gave us so jensen's
inequality tells us that
you know this is i'm going to write this
as
right this is
one possible elbow mix
comma q and theta
and lets
consider another elbow right so for
example
this is another elbow
x q theta
right so for different choices of q
we get different lower bounds of p of x
right and what jensen's inequality tells
us
is that or the corollary tells us is
that
for a given value of theta
let's lets assume this is our randomly
randomly initialize
theta of 0 right for this value of
theta if we choose q to be
p of z given x
theta zero for this choice of q
let us call it q zero
right for this choice if
supposing this is uh the elbow for q
zero then it basically tells us that
the elbow value equals log p
of x at this value of k which means
the elbow touches log p of x
at this value of of theta naught right
when we are at theta naught if we choose
the q
if we choose to construct an elbow using
q as the posterior distribution with
that parameter value
then the elbow will be tight with
respect to
the invisible goal that we are trying to
maximize at that value of theta
and now if we maximize in the m step
if we choose a new theta such that we
maximize
right if this is theta 1
that is the the theta for the next
iteration
and now we construct yet another elbow
right now the new elbow will be
constructing
constructed using you know this q
q one which uses state
q one then
this elbow will be
will be tight at log p of x at theta one
right depending on the uh the choice of
the q
to be equal to the posterior using the
corresponding
theta value the elbow that we'll get
will be tight
i will be touching the the log p of x
that's that's
what jensen's inequality is coral
corollary tells us
now if we started theta naught maximize
the
the elbow that is the m step we get a
new theta 1
construct a new elbow and maximize
that one and we reach here
so this will be theta 2
and here we construct yet another elbow
such that it is tight at
at this value of of of theta 2 and so on
if we
repeat this over and over by
constructing different
lower bounds at each value of theta and
we are maximizing the lower bound
and so on then we will eventually reach
a local optima where the algorithm
converges which means you know theta
stops changing
and that's essentially what the em
algorithm
does so this is the uh the rough
intuition
of or or the or the visual intuition of
how the em algorithm works
and in the next class we will uh we will
go through a proof to show that it
actually converges you know more than
just you know just simply drawing some
pictures
yes questions
yes exactly so how do we compute the
elbow the elbow is
is uh exactly this exactly
so in the next class we'll see an
example of how we apply to gaussian
mixture models where it might
be more clear but for now for you know
for the purpose of this lecture
uh it's enough to have this abstract
view of how the em algorithm works in
general and in the next class we'll
apply it to
gaussian mixture models and see exactly
how each of the steps work
is there any other question yes question
is theta given as z equals theta
transpose x
now theta theta here is some unknown
uh parameter of the model no no that we
don't make any linearity assumptions
you